I am a huge fan of the little princess I
cried and cried and cried for most of
the movie but it's great to see that the
little princess is going to be a
successful woman in the fields of
philanthropy and I would like to focus
on that in terms of how do you invest
your treasure so you are a talented
actress and your hobby is theater I was
wondering how do these interests
translate into your work in philanthropy
and how have the skill sets you
developed in these sectors helped you in
the philanthropic sector that is an
excellent question I think because I've
thought about that a lot because I've
stopped acting professionally now but
there's a lot that I've learned from my
training as an actor that really does
translate so one one of the best lessons
that that I was taught in terms of
acting is whenever you approach is seen
and whatever you approach you know your
relationship with the other character
always ask yourself how do you want to
make the other person feel that directs
your intention and your objective for
that scene so what how are you trying to
make that person feel right then and
there and the thing is I think that
that's actually a better life question
so when you walk into any situation and
when you see someone whether or not they
look like you or whether or not they're
from the same place or whether they have
you know two legs or living in a refugee
camp how do you want to make them feel
and where I think philanthropy then
takes it a step further and development
takes it a step further from theatre is
how not only how do you want to make
them feel in this scene but what about
them in 10 years what about them in 20
years and so development is also about
answering that question as well but I
think that that that kind of and I don't
want to say empathy because it's a
little bit different than empathy but
that thought process absolutely informs
my philanthropy